your beingness is in energy Mastery
School energy Mastery means when another
body comes up and it's talking about oh
my God you know vex me Daddy Let's get
the JB Let's Help be prisoners in our
Matrix cells your energy Mastery you're
learning there is to be like nah
we're going to build the new Earth
all that when someone is suffering
when someone's going through some sort
of pain when someone's going through
some sort of transformation your work in
energy Mastery is helping OB serve them
in whatever they're going through as a
transformation because every time one of
those programs is is obliterated by a
catalyst what's happening is there's a
glitching that's happening and during
that glitching process going towards the
new Earth out of the Matrix towards the
new Earth there's usually the need for
there to be someone there that can
relate to that and help and help them
help be a guide until there's enough
energy Mastery built where one feels
Sovereign and can help those that are
making the transformation themselves
it's actually really beautiful that this
is all energy Mastery and that we can
serve those that are going through their
transformations to become New World
Warriors and ignited